[Music]
the chinese communist party rules its
people with iron control
but as the country grows more powerful
it is extending its grip beyond its
borders
[Music]
sky news can reveal new details of how
china is pressuring other states to do
its bidding trying to intimidate people
into spying on
um
asking authorities to detain and deport
targets they said we will deport your
husband
yes china want him i i asked what's his
crime they said we don't know
one country in particular has been a
happy hunting ground for chinese
security services the united arab
emirates
in the middle of the glitz of dubai the
people on china's list simply vanish
[Music]
spent months speaking to people in
different countries all around the world
what they have in common is that each
one of them became a target for china's
long reach coming for them wherever they
were it is a shadowy world of spies and
thugs of threats and abductions of fear
and of grief here's what we found
xinjiang north west china home to the
uyghur people and other minorities it's
a place that's at the center of china's
crackdown with uyghurs and other
minorities being detained in vast
numbers china says the measures are
necessary to combat extremism many of
the people we've spoken to have been
caught up in that campaign of repression
the first is jizuri burunchi a uighur
man who used to work for a local
communist party committee before leaving
for europe jazeera's ex-wife was a
whistleblower with important information
on the repression in kashgar a city in
xinjiang properly because in august 2019
jizuri got a whatsapp message from a
friend who was still in xinjiang asking
him to meet in dubai
attention
control of india
still he decided to go
he was met at the airport by this man
they took him on a tour of dubai jizure
filming these sites himself the man told
him what he wanted
the heisman
um
but the offer came with a threat as they
were driving through the desert
agreed they told him they'd give him a
usb key all he had to do was insert it
into his wife's computer back in europe
um
he took the usb key and went back to the
netherlands
then he called the police and gave them
the key
but the men kept contacting him
they sent him this video of his mother
they said she was in poor health but
that he could help her by getting the
documents
on
[Music]
the united arab emirates is key to the
stories of all the people we've spoken
to
in recent years china has been hugging
the tiny arab state tight
in 2018 xi jinping himself visited the
first trip by a chinese leader in three
decades his plane was even given an
emirati fighter escort as it landed the
eoe has also signed up to china's belt
and road investment initiative and china
is now one of its largest trading
partners and crucially the two countries
have an extradition treaty
now lives in europe he was a teenager
when he voiced his support for the hong
kong protesters
he had already fled to turkey but his
parents still in china were quickly
detained
and then they came for him in april last
year first
living istanbul hotels
first hotel when sleeping
some
one chinese man
he make phone call to hotel reception
and the hotel reception transfer
telephone to my room
and he told me
you are criminal i will kill you
and also the second day i changed
another hotel but
also these things is happened
wang made plans to go to the us
his flight transited through dubai
when i arrived dubai airport i i need to
go to another depart departure gate on
the road the cid officer then they
stopped me and then told me we have some
questions want to ask you just
very little time because of the
detention center they have a telephone
i use telephone big phone call to my
girlfriend ask her country to buy to
to pay the lawyer to do something help
me
his girlfriend wu hwan arrived the next
day only to be detained too
first at a dubai police station then a
detention center and then somewhere else
um
inside the same black site which he
thinks was somewhere in the outskirts of
the city yeah it's a
far from the camera
and after intervention from u.s
activists both were released
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
are both uyghurs originally from
xinjiang
they both moved to turkey as china's
campaign of repression intensified
but even there their families were not
safe
it was in istanbul that nagari met her
husband hussein
but the turkish authorities came for
hussein too keeping him for months in a
repatriation
um
a year later amanissa her husband ahmed
and their son also traveled to dubai
shopping for clothes for the baby they
were expecting ahmad was detained in a
police station then moved
my husband called me like his voice is
like crying and he said
they took me to another place another
police station i'm not that place and
they did a
urine test and dna test to me
and he said bring the passport my
passport for me and they wanna deport me
soon to china
eloya helped amanesa telling her that
her husband was being detained by
interpol in abu dhabi she went to their
offices
and i explained this is from the
court paper even they didn't look at
this paper
and they said no your husband how to go
we will deport him
because china wants him her last contact
from her husband was in february 2018. a
phone call
hey ask musa my son
and take good care of to your
mommy
when she's pregnant and you are only one
of my son you are boy you have to stay
strong till i come
yes and then the phone was cut
sky news asked the uae turkey and
interpol for a response to our reporting
i received no reply
and we put those allegations directly to
the chinese government we've spoken to
around a dozen people who say that china
is targeting wigas abroad
interrogating them in what they call
black sites pressuring them to spy
on their friends and family secretly
returning them to china
without their loved ones knowing
anything about anything that's happened
to them what's happening here
he also denied that anyone was menaced
overseas or forced to return to china
[Music]
they gave us no information about
nagares and amnesia's husbands
they have disappeared into a world of
shadows
this is where china will continue to
operate
and as its power and economic might
develop its reach will only grow longer
tom cheshire sky news beijing